all right we may have gotten some
information about this very strange
unexplained trip to washington dc that
donald trump made uh sunday night
yesterday we reported on uh some of the
speculation that this may be because
trump is getting arrested or maybe trump
is having some kind of medical
appointment in washington dc or whatnot
the new uh
i don't know that it's necessarily the
consensus but the way things are
pointing is that donald trump flew up to
dc to go to his virginia golf club to
meet with lawyers and aides on the golf
course to avoid the potential
surveillance and media scrutiny that
could take place if such a meeting
actually happened at a lawyer's office
and of course the lawyers that he is
currently meeting with believed to be
believed to be
related to criminal defense that donald
trump may need if indeed he is indicted
so let's go through what we know at this
point business insider reporting trump
spotted at his virginia golf course
after video of him on a flight to the dc
area sparked a firestorm of speculation
now the big
component about this
is that donald trump was on the golf
course and we have a video of it
with no golf clubs
clearly not playing golf and so this was
the start of well what is what is the
point of this what's going on here is
this
sort of a mobster-like meeting
where donald trump is getting away
from media and possible surveillance or
whatever else the case may be and you
see trump driving around in a golf cart
he's not golfing there's no golf clubs
whatsoever and a number of people who
know trump by the way
just
trump going around in a golf cart
there's something just kind of funny and
absurd about it um
this video was shot at quite a distance
by the way so all sorts of different
speculation and questions as to what
this is about michael cohen friend of
the david pakman show and former trump
lawyer who knows trump very very well
uh has a very good tweet thread about
this where he says many are asking me
why mr mushroom putter was at his dc
golf course which is really in virginia
he says to play golf my sources say he
was meeting with two lawyers in secrecy
and didn't trust being at their offices
notice there are no clubs on the cart no
golf clubs on the cart
glad that drudge found this tweet both
newsworthy and humorous for his readers
to enjoy yeah so that's michael cohen's
perspective and indeed when you look
there are no golf clubs there we then
have a uh hold on there was another one
um
which i have no there wasn't that that
is the one so
this seems to basically be the most
logical explanation at this point in
time if donald trump did it
media follows and covers trump to the
degree that they are able to and
informed and know where he's going so we
know the trip to dc
was unannounced that doesn't mean it was
necessarily unplanned it might have been
planned at the last minute and media
were not told about it uh if donald
trump had ended up at walter reed or at
some kind of medical center it would be
known it would have become news and so
this now is the most likely explanation
which is trump uh paranoid trump
surveillance concerned trump or whatever
it is you want to say
wanted to meet with people
outside of the range
of whatever it was that he was paranoid
about and it all is believed to be
related to donald trump's need for
criminal lawyers
as we potentially get closer and closer
to an indictment now let's talk a little
bit about the indictment as is often the
case we saw this with matt gates and
this is ongoing with matt gates
there is a search warrant there is news
of an investigation and then there is no
indictment immediately or whatever and
people start emailing me and asking
questions about well
when is the indictment coming
and when it comes to the trump
indictment it is
completely plausible that we are still
months from such an indictment if one is
coming it takes a long time to complete
this these investigations and again
there's still an if as to whether trump
is going to get indicted i can only
assume based on the amount of
seriousness
and planning
with which the search warrant was
approved on trump fbi approval attorney
general approval
uh judge signature all of the things
that must be done that have to be done
when you are doing something like this
with a former president i can only
imagine that it's going to take more
than the few weeks that remain between
now and the midterm election
for
final decisions to be made about
charging or not charging trump what
would be in that indictment and there is
also a there are some reports that
the charges would not be made before the
election to avoid the appearance of of
polit trying to have political influence
i actually think that it's less likely
that that's the explanation and it's
more likely that it just takes time to
put charges like this together we will
follow it
i've had such trouble finding a great
razor where i am not cutting myself or
getting those nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
henson shaving henson actually
manufactures parts for the international
space station and the mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
precision engineering to the shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
aerospace grade cnc machines henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just 0.001
inches that's less than the thickness of
a human hair which means a secure stable
blade with a vibration free shave it
also has built-in channels to evacuate
the hair and the cream no more clogs no
more rubbing your thumb on the razor to
get the hair out i use henson at home
shaving is a great experience now henson
wants to be the best razor not the best
razer business which means you only need
to buy it once and it's awesome go to
hensonshaving.com
pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
pacman and you will get the razors for
free that is a three year supply my
friends the link is down below